meine sehr geehrten damen und herren der
bundesvorstand der cdu deutschlands hat
heute einstimmig den beschluss der
präsidiumssitzung vom vergangenen
freitag zur situation in thüringen
unterstützt und damit auch meine ganz
klare haltung keine annäherung und keine
zusammenarbeit mit der ard und der
linken die afg steht gegen alles was uns
als cdu aus macht jede anhörung an die
afg schwächt die cdu
ich stehe für eine cdu die jede form der
direkten und indirekten zusammenarbeit
mit der afg ganz klar ablehnt und das
hat der bundesvorstand heute
eindrücklich unterstrichen geschichte
und programmatik der partei die linke
sind mit kernpunkten der grundsätze der
cdu deutschlands absolut unvereinbar
eine zusammenarbeit der cdu mit der
linken kann es nicht geben
wir spüren derzeit starke fliehkräfte in
unserer gesellschaft und in unserer
volkspartei cdu und wir spüren es kommt
auf uns an
wir müssen stark sein stärker seien
stärker als heute
es ist eine aufgabe für uns alle für
eine starke cdu zu sorgen auch darin bin
ich mir einig mit allen
führungsmitgliedern in präsidium und der
bundesvorstand aber meine sehr geehrten
damen und herren diese aufgabe liegt in
besonderer weise bei mir als
parteivorsitzender mit der aufgabe des
parteivorsitzes durch angela merkel und
der trennung von kanzlerschaft und
parteivorsitz haben wir eine in der cdu
geübte praxis aufgegeben
es hat sich bis in die jüngsten tage
gezeigt dass damit eine ungeklärte
führungsfrage einher geht nämlich die
frage nach der kanzlerkandidatur
diese frage ist trotz zweier parteitage
nicht zur ruhe gekommen und sollte nach
dem willen einiger offenbar auch für die
zukunft nicht zur ruhe kommen
die trennung von kanzlerschaft und
parteivorsitz
die offene frage der kanzlerkandidatur
schwächt die cdu in einer phase in der
politik in deutschland in der dieses
system und in der deutschland auf eine
starke cdu angewiesen ist
vor fast genau zwei jahren hat mich der
parteitag der cdu deutschlands zu seiner
generalsekretärin gewählt
ich habe damals mein hart erkämpftes
staatsamt der ministerpräsidentin des
saarlandes aufgegeben um mich in den
dienst der partei zu stellen
das war damals und ist auch heute meine
maxime
denn ich habe wie manch andere auch
dieser cdu sehr sehr viel zu verdanken
ich wusste damals dass es eine
schwierige zeit wird und die letzten
beiden jahre haben das bestätigt
aus all diesen gründen und mit der
intention die cdu zu stärken habe ich
deshalb heute dem präsidium und dem
bundesvorstand nach reiflicher
überlegung meine folgende entscheidung
mitgeteilt
ich werde mich nicht um eine
kanzlerkandidatur bewerben
ich führe so wie ich das angekündigt
haben den prozess unter einem kanzler
kandidat oder an der kanzlerkandidatin
der cdu der union gemeinsam zu kommen
weiter von vorne
wir haben dazu verfahren vereinbart
nämlich dass wir auf einem parteitag
eine entsprechende programmatische
plattform eine organisatorische form und
die inhaltliche frage und die personelle
frage klären wollen damit wir aus einer
guten position in das wahljahr starten
können dieses ziel besteht weiterhin
für mich ist aber auch ganz klar dass
ich mit meinen verzicht auf eine eigene
kandidatur diesen prozess sehr viel
freier gestalten kann
denn alles was dazu mut
es ist kann ich angehen ohne dass man
mir unterstellt dass sich dies in einem
eigenen interesse tour parteivorsitz und
kanzlerkandidatur müssen aus meiner
sicht am ende aber in einer hand liegen
deswegen werde ich so lange
parteivorsitzende bleiben bis die
entscheidung über die kanzlerkandidatur
getroffen ist und dann das parteiamt in
die entsprechende hände abgeben wenn
dies delegierten auf einem parteitag
genau so sehen das amt der
bundesministerin der verteidigung werde
ich auf wunsch der bundeskanzlerin
fortführen und mich bis zum ende der
legislaturperiode mit aller kraft für
unsere soldatinnen und soldaten
einsetzen und um das noch einmal zu
unterstützen ich bin sehr dankbar dass
ich heute gesagt habe dass ich bereit
bin verteidigungsministerin zu bleiben
wenn die bundeskanzlerin und wenn die
bundestagsfraktion die so wünscht dass
das von beiden seiten so unterstützt
wurden ist denn wir liegen die
soldatinnen und soldaten sehr am herzen
bin dann für die erste frage an herrn
blank bitte das war das statement von
annegret kramp karrenbauer zu ihrem
rückzug als parteivorsitzende cd der cdu
und zu ihrem verzicht als
kanzlerkandidatin fragen wir konnten am
energy im hauptstadtstudio berlin das
war jetzt ein vor formuliertes
politisches statement du als
hauptstadtkorrespondent in kennt sich
damit bestens aus kannst du noch mal
zusammenfassen und übersetzen was sie
gesagt hat
also ich denke sie hat im kern zwei
dinge gesagt zum einen hat sie vorne
nochmal ganz deutlich gemacht dass sie
heute noch einmal einstimmige
rückendeckung des vorstandes bekommen
hat für ihr vorgehen in thüringen damit
will der vorstand sie offensichtlich ein
wenig entlasten und nicht die
gesamtschuld bei ihr auf ihren schultern
sehen
zum anderen hat sie als ursache für ihre
führungsschwäche ganz klar einen punkt
genannt nämlich die trennung des
parteivorsitzes und des kanzleramt ist
das hat es ja vor dem jetzigen zeitpunkt
bevor angela
merkel sich vom parteivorsitz
zurückgezogen hat das kanzleramt aber
nicht abgegeben hat in der cdu so noch
nicht gegeben
und wenn ich sie da richtig verstehe ist
dass auch ein stückweit kritik an angela
merkel die in den im letzten jahr
durchaus aus der eigenen partei immer
wieder zeichen bekommen hat dass das
eine schwierige konstellation ist sich
aber trotzdem nicht zurückgezogen hat
sie hat sich gleichzeitig nicht in die
innenpolitik eingemischt hat dieses
schwierige feld und die die machtkämpfe
die dort auch stattfinden
annegret kramp karrenbauer alleine
überlassen und das schwingt hier alles
mit in der erklärung die annegret kramp
karrenbauer gerade gegeben hat als sie
gesagt hat das ist ein zustand der so
nicht haltbar ist sie hat das nicht
wörtlich gesagt aber im prinzip hat sie
gesagt so kann man eine partei nicht
führen und der die unausgesprochene
machtfrage
die sei eben nicht beendet gewesen in
dem moment als die parteivorsitzende
geworden ist weil es quasi hinter den
kulissen immer noch die tautz das
tauziehen gegeben hat um die frage wer
wird denn einmal nachfolgerin von angela
merkel im kanzleramt falls die cdu eine
wahl gewinnen sollte die sie dazu in die
lage versetzte kanzler zu stellen muss
man natürlich dazu sagen so dass der mit
ihrem rückzug heißt das ja nicht
automatisch dass ein machtkampf
innerhalb der partei beendet ist da wird
da nun wahrscheinlich erst richtig
losgehen
ja da kann jetzt natürlich ganz offen
ausbrechen also sowie annegret
kramp-karrenbauer das gerade ausgedrückt
hat und wir haben das hier natürlich
auch beobachtet hat der machtkampf
tatsächlich nie aufgehört es gibt
verschiedene lager in der partei die
einen sagen wir müssen wieder deutlich
konservativer werden das profil in diese
richtung schärfen
auch das thema wirtschaft haben wir aus
den augen verloren
wir haben heute morgen henning otte den
mitglieder beauftragten der cdu gehört
der ganz deutlich gesagt hat wer auch
immer jetzt im parteivorsitz übernimmt
muss auch akzeptiert werden von dem
konservativen flügel und von den
wirtschaftsliberalen in der cdu und auf
der anderen seite haben wir eben
diejenigen die gesagt haben wenn wir als
volkspartei in der breite bestehen
wollen dürfen wir nicht zu weit nach
rechts rücken und auch keine
gedankenspiele mit der afg machen das
hat ja der vorstand
da auch noch mal ganz klar bestätigt
keine zusammenarbeit mit der afd
aber auch keine zusammenarbeit mit der
linken das muss man auch dazu sagen dass
wir hier in der erklärung auch noch
einmal ganz deutlich es ist heute der
versuch gewesen von annegret kramp
karrenbauer noch einmal einen pflock
einzuschlagen zu sagen wir versuchen die
cdu in der mitte zu halten
nur wie sieht das jetzt machen will als
parteivorsitzender auf abruf die
eigentlich nur noch organisatorische
prozesse managen möchte mit einer
kanzlerin an ihrer seite die sich auch
nicht mehr einmischt in die belange der
der partei das ist völlig offen
und welchen eindruck hat sie eben in der
pressekonferenz auf dicht gemacht
einen sehr gefassten denke ich wir haben
sie in den letzten tagen ohnehin sehr
angespannt und zum teil auch sehr müde
gesehen sie hat sehr viele gespräche
geführt sie ist nach thüringen gefahren
sie hat an keiner stelle einen echten
erfolg feiern können sie hat zwar klare
beschlüsse vorgelegt die aber so in
thüringen nicht mitgetragen worden sind
und von tag zu tag ist offensichtlicher
geworden dass die partei eben nicht
geschlossen hinter der linie steht die
sie selber ausgerufen hat und das muss
sie natürlich als parteivorsitzende
mitnehmen sie hat es ja auch ganz klar
gesagt dass sie offensichtlich nicht die
kraft gehabt hat für eine starke cdu zu
sorgen so hat sie es gesagt sie hat
gesagt eine besondere aufgabe die vor
allem bei ihr läge und ich zitiere mal
sie hat gesagt die das ganze prozedere
die trennung von parteivorsitz und
kanzleramt und dadurch auch die
schwächung der parteivorsitzenden
schwächt die cdu in einer phase in der
deutschland auf eine starke cdu
angewiesen ist also sie hat damit
natürlich auch die führungsschwäche
eingeräumt hat aber gleichzeitig auch
darauf verwiesen dass es nicht allein
ihre schuld sei und dann wollen wir
jetzt am schluss den blick nach vorne
richten welche namen kommen da jetzt ins
spiel
ja nach öffentlich nach vorne gegangen
ist heute noch niemand aber es ist
eigentlich bekannt wer in den
startlöchern steht da ist zum einen ganz
sparen der gesundheitsminister der sich
ja auch schon um den parteivorsitz
beworben hatte und unterlägen es gegen
annegret kramp karrenbauer
er hat im letzten jahr sehr auffällig
sehr viele prestige projekte angeschoben
und auch dafür gesorgt dass man
mitbekommen hat wo er erfolgreich seine
projekte platziert hat und durchgesetzt
hat als gesundheitsminister da ist
friedrich merz der sein comeback
gefeiert hat seit seit er sich um den
parteivorsitz beworben hat obwohl auch
er gegen annegret kramp karrenbauer
unterlegen ist erst ein bisschen der
hoffnungsträger des konservativen
flügels und auch der so genannten werte
union eines vereins der eigentlich
außerhalb der cdu liegt aber viele cdu
mitglieder hat der immer wieder auch
gesagt hat wir müssen uns nach rechts
öffnen wir müssen mit der afg auch
sprechen die haben schon mal gesagt
friedrich merz wäre ein guter kandidat
er selber will sich mit einer mit der
werte union nicht in verbindung sehen
aber es auf jeden fall ein
hoffnungsträger für konservative kreise
in der cdu und dann gibt es da noch
armin laschet der immer wieder im
gespräch war der sich selber nie
geäußert hat der stünde er für den kurs
den angriff kramp karrenbauer heute noch
einmal skizziert hat nicht mit der
linken kooperieren nicht mit der afg
kooperieren und irgendwie versuchen in
der mitte wieder stark zu werden das
wäre eine fortsetzung in in der politik
in eine kontinuität von angela merkel
über annegret kramp karrenbauer zu armin
laschet
wenn es denn so käme ob das jetzt
tatsächlich die neuaufstellung ist für
die eine grid kramp karrenbauer den weg
frei machen möchte das muss man dann
auch sehen also das personalkarussell
wird sich in der cdu noch turbulent
weiter drehen in den nächsten monaten
und ihr werdet uns darüber weiter auf
dem laufenden halten vielen dank stark
und aller welt
für informationen hintergründe analysen
und wir sagen damit vielen dank fürs
zuschauen und wünschen noch einen
schönen tag
[Musik]